لتحرير الفلوجه من داعش اطرت القوات
العراقيه لتدمير مساحه كبيره من المدينه
حيث دمرت الكثير من المباني الواحده
والاخرى تم تليين المدينه بحسب المفهوم
العسكري عبر قصفها بالاليات الثقيله عن
طريق البر والجو لايام قبل ان تدخل القوات
العراقيه الى
وسطها نحن الان داخل هذه المدرعه التابعه
للقوات العراقيه متجهين الى احد الاحياء
في الجنوب الشرقي
للفلو سمعنا اصوات اطلاق نار من داخل الحي
وسمعنا ايضا اصوات
المدفعيه لنرى ما الذي سنجده في
الداخل سالت الجنود داخل المدرعه اذا ما
زال داعش في
المدينه لا ليس هناك داعش علق جاسم الذي
خدم بالجيش لاث عاما حيث بين لنا ان هناك
جيب او جيبان هنا وهناك لا يزال القتال
فيهما
مستمرا لكننا اكتشفنا ان هذه الجيوب عديده
وتبدو انها
عميقه هذا هو حي النزال في وسط الفلوجه
وقد كان تحت سيطره داعش الى اول امس لكننا
نرى العديد من جنود القوات العراقيه
والمدرعات في داخله غير ان الذي لا نراه
هو اي من
المدنيين هذا الضابط الذي طلب منا مناداته
بابو مريم قال انه راى العديد من المدنيين
وهم يفرون من
المدينه لقد كانوا مرهقين جدا ويعانون من
قله الماء
والطعام توقع مسؤولون العراقيون مقاومه
اقوى داخل الفلوجه حيث تعتبر اول مدينه
استولى عليها داعش قبل عامين
ونصف لكن القوات العراقيه نجحت بالتغلغل
داخل المدينه واكد الضباط ان مقاومه داعش
تبعثرت احكم قناص حاليا قال نسيم بدري ان
هناك عدد قليل من القناصه والجيش يتعامل
معهم وسيقضي عليهم
قريبا مجموعه من الجنود العراقيين تمكنوا
من انتزاع احد اعلام داعش اما تحرير
المدينه من ناحيه اخرى فما زال عمليه
جاريه